Hallo, guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Ekrem Özübalı.
Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistent Ars Tetic.
Heute würde ich gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Alles in Ordnung für Sie.
Ja, ich denke, das ist gut.
Ihre Stimme kommt ein bisschen leise.
Können Sie bitte einmal kontrollieren?
Sehr sehr leise.
Jetzt?
Noch mal bitte.
Ohne Kopfhörer versuche ich.
Jetzt? Wie ist es?
Geht jetzt besser.
Ok. Ja, Herr Doktor, ich heiße Florian Wilms.
Florian?
Wilms.
Florian Wilms.
Herr Wilms, können Sie bitte Ihre Phonomen und Nachnamen langsam und deutlich bezeichnen?
Florian ist F, L, O, R, I, I, D und A am Ende N.
Ok. Und?
Und Wilms?
V, I, L, M und am Ende S wie Samuel.
Am Ende S. Vielen Dank.
Herr Wilms, wie alt sind Sie?
Ja, ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
42 Jahre alt. Ok.
Wann sind Sie geboren?
Am 2.2.1982.
Können Sie bitte nochmal wiederholen?
Ja, 2. April, Entschuldigung, Februar, 1982.
Ok. Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Wilms?
Ich bin 1,87 Meter groß.
1,87 Meter?
Ja.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 94,5 Kilo.
94,5 Kilo.
Genau.
Können Sie bitte nochmal Ihren Kopfhörer auftragen?
Ok. Jetzt?
Ja.
Können Sie mich gut hören?
Ja, jetzt ein bisschen.
Ok.
Vielen Dank, Herr Wilms. Was wissen Sie uns, Herr Wilms?
Herr Doktor, seit ungefähr zwei Stunden habe ich plötzlich so einen Dumpf- und drückenden Schmerz hinter dem Brustbein.
Hinter dem Brustbein?
Ja.
Zwei Stunden?
Dumpf und?
Ja, kann ich auch drücken sagen.
Drücken?
Ja.
Ach so.
Der ist einfach auf einmal gekommen und hat mich ehrlich gesagt ziemlich beunruhigt.
Ja, ich verstehe. Nur in einem bestimmten Bereich oder in dem Brustkorb?
Hinter dem Brustkorb, Frau Doktor.
Ok.
Brustbein, Entschuldigung. Hinter dem Brustbein.
Ja, hinter dem Brustbein.
Ja, ja.
In der Mitte der Brust. Also direkt hinter dem Brustbein.
Ok. Hinter dem Brustbein und in der Mitte. Herr Wilms strahlende Schmerzen, etenbrüchen aus.
Zum Beispiel in den Rücken oder unter Bauch.
Linkenarm.
Ja.
Herr Wilms, diese Beschwerden sind ganz neu oder? Vorher haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden?
Letzten hatte ich ähnliche Beschwerden. Letzten Jahr. Zwei bis dreimal im Sommer.
Aber das war nur bei Belastung. Wenn ich bewege oder mich belaste, hatte ich diese Beschwerden.
Früher aber jetzt sind Sie in Ruhe aufgetreten.
Jetzt in Ruhe aufgetreten. Ja.
Haben Sie Luftnoten oder Ängergefühl?
Jetzt? Was meine ich?
Ängergefühl. Ja, ich habe auch Ängergefühl.
Ok. Herr Wilms, da besteht ein Notfallverdacht. Jetzt muss ich das auch nochmal geschüttelt unterbrechen.
Und dann werde ich diese körperliche Untersuchung, ein paar Labouruntersuchungen durchführen.
Sofort eine Elektrocardiogramm verschreiben.
Wenn alles gut läuft, können wir unsere Aufnahmegespräche weiterführen.
Ok. Bevor ich weiter aufnachdenke.
Haben Sie damit verstanden? Ja. Ok.
Herr Wilms, können wir weiterführen?
Ja bitte.
Herr Wilms, Sie haben schon gesagt, das Chimmascharakter ist dumpf, dökend.
Haben Sie noch Ängergefühl? Und wie stark sind die Schmerzen? Wie beschreiben Sie auf einer Schmerzkala, wobei nur kein Schmerzen, sehr sehr stark Schmerzen entspricht?
Währenddessen waren Sie eine 6 von 10. Aber jetzt besser. 4 von 10.
Aber es dauert noch. Ok.
Leiden Sie manchmal Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Ja, Herr Doktor. Ich habe auch Herzklopfen.
Herzklopfen. Ok.
Herr Wilms, gibt es eine bestimmte Auslöser für die Beschwerden?
Ich habe nicht. Wie gesagt, war ich zu Hause und nur habe ich mich gesessen.
Ok.
Gibt es etwas, das die Beschwerden verstärkt, wie Sie schon gesagt haben, Bewegung oder Linder?
Zum Beispiel in Ruhe oder?
Das habe ich nicht, Herr Doktor.
Aber momentan haben Sie noch in Ruhe, solche Beschwerden.
Heute Morgen sind Sie in Ruhe aufgetreten.
Ok. Herr Wilms, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Aber mir ist übel.
Ja, Sie sind übel. Ist Ihnen auch Schwindel?
Nein, Schwindel habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie noch Erbrüche?
Nein, nur Übelkeit habe ich.
Ok. Waren Sie schon wegen dieser Schmerzen zu Hause gewesen?
Aber ich fühle mich auch müde, Herr Doktor. Ich schwitze viel und habe viel geschwitzt.
Haben Sie schon geschwitzt?
Meine Tochter sagte mir, dass ich blass war.
Ok. Haben Sie Kaltschweiß? Nachschwanz?
Ja, genau. Ich habe auch Kaltschweißigkeit.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Herzklopfen, Herzrasen.
Haben Sie noch Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie noch Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Ok. Wie ist Ihr Apathetik und Durst in der letzten Zeit?
Ich habe derzeit keinen Hunger mehr, Herr Doktor.
Haben Sie einmal Gewichtsverlust?
Ich habe in den letzten drei Jahren 3 Kilo zugenommen.
Nicht Gewichtsverlust, aber ich habe zugenommen.
In der letzten Zeit? Ich meinte ganz andere. Danke für die Information.
Haben Sie noch Gewichtsverlust?
Nein.
Ok. Aber in wie viel Zeit haben Sie 3 Kilo zugenommen?
In den letzten drei Jahren.
Ich hatte früher immer Gewicht, aber...
Haben Sie noch Gewichtsverlust?
Nein.
Ok.
Eine geschwollene Beine.
Und Herr Wimms, haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Schlafen Sie gut?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie flach liegen,
haben Sie noch Atemnot oder Herzrasen oder irgendwelche Probleme?
Doktor, tatsächlich schlafe ich zurzeit nachts nicht gut, weil ich Angst habe, zu sterben.
Egal, flach liegen oder nicht. Aber...
zurzeit schlafe ich nicht gut.
Wenn ich richtig verstanden habe, Sie haben eine Todangst, oder? Was meinen Sie?
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Meinen Sie...
Ich meine Todangst.
Seit gestern oder vorhin.
Seit einem Jahr habe ich solche Gefühle. Aber ich... ja.
Leiden Sie unter der Arbeitsbelastung oder gibt es eine bestimmte Depressionendiagnose oder psychologische bekannte Probleme?
Doktor, ich habe keine psychologischen Probleme.
Ja, Arbeitsbelastung.
Gibt es bei Ihnen?
Doktor...
Ja, ok.
Manchmal stresse ich meinen Beruf. Ich bin Speditionskaufmann.
Ok.
Wissen Sie, was das ist?
Ich meine einfach Arbeitsbelastung. Ich habe sehr viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Nicht viel Stress. Manchmal habe ich Stress.
Ok, vielen Dank.
Ok.
Herr Binz, haben Sie oder leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Arthralhypertonie, Bluthochdruck oder sowas?
Doktor, ich habe keinen Hausarzt.
Deswegen weiß ich nicht mein aktuelles Gesundheitszustand.
Ich kann es nicht gut beurteilen.
Aber ich habe chronische Hüsten.
Ich verstehe. Sie haben chronische Hüsten und seit wann haben Sie keinen Hausarzt?
Seit wann waren Sie letztes Mal bei Ihrem Hausarzt für die Kontrolle?
Vielleicht vor fünf Jahren.
Vor?
Fünf Jahren.
Fünf, fünf Jahre. Ok. Aber das ist sehr wichtig für Mindesten.
Einmal in einem Jahr zum Hausarzt besuchen.
Sehr wichtig für Ihre Gesundheit.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben eine chronische Hüste. Seit wann?
Seit zehn Jahren.
Leider ist es so.
Brauchen Sie, Herr Binz?
Ja, Herr Doktor, ich rauche vielleicht 20 Zigaretten täglich.
20 Zigaretten täglich? Seit wann?
Früher war es ein bisschen weniger als jetzt.
Seitdem ich 18 Jahre alt war, rauche ich.
Ok.
Ich habe mehrmals versucht, aber das hat nicht geklappt.
Ich kann es gut nachvollziehen, aber können wir Ihnen eine professionelle Unterstützung anbieten?
Wenn Sie möchten.
Ja, aber nicht jetzt. Vielleicht später.
Zurück zu Ihnen. Gibt es eine bestimmte Diagnose für Ihre Hüste?
Damals hat der Arzt gesagt, aufgrund des Rauchens hatte ich diese Krankheit oder diese Beschwerde.
Gibt es einen Auswurf oder einen Druck oder mit dem Auswurf?
Zurück habe ich besonders morgens.
Wie sah es aus?
Manchmal gelblich.
Als ich 25 Jahre alt war, hatte ich vergrößerte Lymphknoten wegen Virus.
Wo war das?
Lymphknoten im Hals.
Lymphknoten im Hals wegen eines Virus. Welche Infektionen hatten Sie?
Der Arzt hat gesagt, was für ein Virus habe ich.
Ja, ein Cyto-Megalowirus.
Hat der Arzt so gesagt.
Sie kennen das.
Jetzt konnte ich daran erinnern.
Danke für die Information. Herr Wülm, sehr wütige Information für uns.
Gibt es noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Reicht das nicht?
Entschuldigung. Würden Sie schon mal operieren?
Ja, wegen des Autounfalls hatte ich Fraktoren am Unterschenkel.
Deswegen wurde ich operiert.
Mit Platten oder ohne Platten?
Ohne Platten.
Und wann?
Als ich 20 war.
20 Jahre. Wegen eines Autounfalls.
Ich habe das nicht gehört.
Das war eine Komplikation?
Ja.
Sie haben kein Problem erlebt.
Haben Sie eine Allergie?
Nein.
Gibt es noch Unvertragliche Karten?
Sie haben keine Unvertragliche Karten?
Nein.
Okay, super.
Herr Wülm,
brauchen Sie eine Medikament?
Ich nehme nur eine Schleimlösung.
Kennen Sie die Namen?
Es gibt drei Buchstaben.
Vielleicht ACC kann es sein.
SS oder CC.
CC.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr an die Dosis erinnern.
Die auf der Packung stand.
Aber ich nehme nur eine Tablette täglich.
Täglich? Was gibt es?
Ich nehme Schima.
Wegen?
Wegen meinem Auswurf.
Ist das eine ärztliche Rat?
Ja, damals hat mein Hausarzt das verschrieben.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Gibt es andere Medikamente?
Nein, nur dieses Medikament nehme ich.
Herr Wülm,
Sie rauchen seit dem 18. Lebensjahr
in der letzten Zeit eine Schachtel Zigaretten pro Tag.
Vorher war das ein bisschen weniger.
Durchschnittlich 20 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Ich empfehle Ihnen,
mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören.
Das ist sehr gut für Ihre Gesundheit.
Ich habe viel mehrmals versucht, damit aufzuhören.
Ich habe gesagt,
aber das ist nicht so einfach, damit aufzuhören.
Rauchen Sie auch?
Ja.
Warum?
Wieso konnten Sie es schaffen?
Ich habe auch gleiche Probleme.
Ich möchte nicht darüber sprechen.
Okay.
Herr Wülm, ich verstehe Sie sehr gut.
Sie haben recht.
Ist das Alkohol, Herr Wülm?
Ja, Doktor.
Ich trinke am Wochenende nur.
Ein oder zwei Gläser Flaschen Bier.
Oder nicht Gläser, Flaschen Bier.
Oder zwei bis drei Gläser Wein.
Oder Wein.
Am Wochenende.
Aber nicht gleichzeitig.
Nicht gleichzeitig.
Ich achte darauf.
Okay, super.
Herr Wülm, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Haben Sie noch einmal Drogen ausprobiert?
Ist das eine Routinefrage?
Ja, ich verstehe.
An der Universität habe ich einmal probiert.
Danach nie.
Ja, bei jungen Jahren.
Einmal nur.
Okay.
Als Drogen gab es Kaffee an?
Als Drogen gab es Kaffee.
Es war eine Drogen, aber eine legale Drogen mit Tabak.
Kein Problem.
Wir nehmen alle Kaffee.
Ich mache weiter, viel Kaffee zu trinken.
Nicht so viel.
Das wäre gut.
Ich trinke viel Kaffee.
Leider.
Ausgewogene Ernährungen sind sehr wichtig für uns.
Herr Dimmz, gibt es in Ihrer Familie eine Erkrankung?
Blutzucker, Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Leben lehren noch?
Mein Vater ist leider mit 50 Jahren an Herzschlag verstorben.
Er hatte Bluthochdruck und Grünärschter.
Und Grünärschter.
Ich habe Angst, wie mein Vater Herzschlag zu haben.
Werd ich davon sterben?
Bitte denken Sie so nicht.
Aber ich kann Ihre Beschwerden gut nachvollziehen.
Wir werden alle Möglichkeiten überprüfen.
Und dann können wir weiter über diese Probleme sprechen.
Bitte seien Sie ein bisschen ruhig.
Herr Doktor, bezüglich Grünärschter habe ich noch eine Frage.
Darf ich?
Bitte.
Ist Grünärschter erblich?
Kann meine Tochter daran leiden?
Ich frage mich.
Grünärschter ist keine erbliche Krankheit.
Es ist bezüglich des inneren Augendruckes.
Das muss mit Kommandos behandelt werden.
Aber ich bin kein Speziale über die Augenkrankheit.
Sie sollen mit einem speziellen Sprit dafür.
Und Ihre Mutter? Ist sie gesund?
Sie lebt noch, aber leider hat sie auch Probleme.
Sie leidet an Rheuma.
Rheuma?
Ja, Rheuma.
Okay.
Unterkontrolle?
Sie nimmt Medikamente ein.
Medikamente behandelt. Okay.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester.
Sie hat auch viele gesundheitliche Probleme.
Sie ist übergewischt, Herr Doktor.
Übergewischt.
Sie hat Depressionen und Warizen in beiden Beinen.
Depressionen und Warizen. Okay.
Ich habe das nicht.
Sie hat Blaustreifen unter der Haut.
Wenn Sie übergewischt haben, kann es sein.
Meistens.
Aber ich denke, wegen dieser Warizen hat sie diese Blaustreifen unter der Haut.
Generell als theoretisch, das ist so.
Aber man muss erst einmal einen körperlichen Untersuch von...
Sie sollen mit einem Gefäßschirurken einen Termin vereinbart.
Es wäre besser für Sie.
Und Herr Wimms, was machen Sie beruflich?
Er sagt, ich bin Speditionkaufmann.
Speditionkaufmann?
Ja.
Speditions-n.
Es gibt es zwischen beiden Wörtern.
Ja, Speditionkaufmann.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Auf dem Papier bin ich verheiratet.
Aber wir leben...
Weil Sie getrennt sind.
Ja.
Herr Wimms, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja Doktor, ich habe eine Tochter und ich lebe mit ihr.
Eine Tochter.
Ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie hat nur Hühnerauge.
Hühnerauge.
Ihre Tochter hat eine Hühnerauge.
Ja.
Sie ist 11 Jahre alt?
11 Jahre alt.
Was soll ich machen dagegen oder dafür, Herr Doktor?
Ich meine Hühnerauge.
Zu welchem Art soll ich sie bringen?
Hühnerauge, wie Sie wissen, Herr Wimms,
hat eine orthopädische Probleme.
Am Fuß sollen Sie eine orthopädische Termin vereinbaren.
Okay.
Für Ihre Tochter.
Ihre Tochter sollte bequeme Schuhe tragen.
Ich habe gegoogelt und das habe ich dort erfahren.
Und jetzt achten wir darauf.
Okay.
Hühnerauge entsteht unter hohem Druck.
Soll Ihre Tochter bequeme Schuhe ansehen.
Okay.
Sie sind spät in diesem Kaufmann getrennt.
Haben Sie noch eine Tochter?
Und Herr Wimms, ich bin nun mit meiner Fragung fertig.
Ich bedanke mich für Ihre Offenheit.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Doktor, was haben Sie bei der Untersuchung gefunden?
Sie haben einen EKG geschrieben.
Hatten Sie Probleme bei meinem Herz?
Ja, Herr Wimms, Sie haben noch ein paar Probleme.
Bezüglich Ihren Herzgesundheit.
Ich habe den Verdacht, Sie haben ein akutes Coronaszentrum.
Deswegen sollen wir ein paar Untersuchungen bei Ihnen durchführen.
Wir haben schon Labo-Untersuchungen durchgeführt und einen EKG veranlasst.
Und brauchen wir noch weitere Diagnosen durchführen.
Sobald Ihre Ergebnisse vorliegen, bespreche ich mit meinem Obar über Ihre Situation.
Ich komme sofort zurück zu Ihnen und erzähle Ihnen alles Schritt für Schritt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas fragen?
Nein, Herr Doktor. Danke für alle Informationen.
Vielen Dank, Herr Wimms. Wir sehen uns. Bis gleich.
Das war es, Frau Oberöstin.
Ich habe meinen Verdacht, Diagnosen vergessen.
Vielen Dank.
Ipek Avla, möchtest du einen Anruf machen?
Ja, Kling-Kling.
Außer Hippokalemie.
Außer dem, ja?
Ja, außer dem.
Okay.
Östliche Anruf.
Guten Morgen. Ich bin Frau Müller.
Frau Schäfer, Nattschiffwert 168.
Frau Schäfer, können Sie mir bitte einmal buchstabieren?
Ja, SCH wie Schule und H.
SCH?
Ja, ja, ja. SCH wie Schule und E wie Ökonomie.
Ja.
Nein. E wie A umlaut.
Okay.
E wie Erger, Entschuldigung.
Und E wie Frederik, E wie Emil, A wie Richard.
Okay, Frau Schäfer.
Mhm.
Okay, Frau Schäfer. Was hat Frau Schäfer?
Nattschiffwert 168.
168, ja, bin deutlich erhöht. Okay.
168.
Millimol pro Liter.
Ja, Millimol pro Liter.
Die Einheit ist Millimol pro Liter.
Könnten Sie mit dieser Werte Ihre Oberarztin weiterleiten?
Okay, vielen Dank, Frau Müller. Danke für die Information. Auf Wiedersehen.
Schönen Tag.
Frau Oberarztin.
Guten Tag.
Ja, guten Tag. Ich habe einen neuen Patient, aber bevor ich meinen Patienten vorstelle, möchte ich Ihnen etwas Wichtiges mitteilen.
Bevor Sie mit mir etwas Wichtiges mitteilen, möchte ich Sie bitte vorstellen.
Okay, Frau Oberarztin. Mein Name ist Ekrem Özvalo. Ich komme aus der Türkei.
Seit drei Jahren lebe ich in Deutschland.
Und seit drei Jahren lerne ich Deutsch.
Und alle Progriffe B1, B2 und Fachsprachprüfung Kurs habe ich in Deutschland abgelegt.
Außer für die Fachsprachprüfung.
Ich war in der Türkei normalerweise Urologin.
Und ca. zehn Jahre als Urologin Facharzt gearbeitet habe.
Jetzt möchte ich in Zukunft wieder als Arzt, als Urologe in Deutschland arbeiten.
Und deswegen bin ich hier.
Man darf sich fragen, warum Sie nach Deutschland gekommen sind.
Sie sind schon Facharzt in der Türkei und Sie haben viel Erfahrung.
Ja, wegen politischen Gründen. Das ist ganz unwillkürlich.
Ungewollt wegen politischen Gründen. Ich und meine Familie müssten nach Deutschland auswandeln.
Okay. Bitte schön. Was haben Sie noch heute für uns?
Frau Oberarztin, ich habe noch einen neuen Patienten.
Er geht um Florian Wims.
Florian Wims ist 42 Jahre alt.
Geboren am 2. Oktober 1982.
1,87 Meter groß und 94,5 Kilo aktuell.
Florian Wims stellte sich heute bei uns wegen der 3 Stunden aufgetretenen, dumpf und drückenden Brustschmerzen vor.
Die Schmerzen strahlen im linken Arm und im Halsbereich.
Am Anfang waren die Schmerzen dunst und sichert.
Aber im Moment sind die Schmerzkarakteren meist drückend.
Die Patienten haben die ähnliche Beschwerden seit 2 Jahren.
Die Patienten haben keine bestimmten Auslöser.
Vorher waren diese Beschwerden nur beim Bewegung aufgetreten.
Aber jetzt treten die Schmerzen in Ruhe auf.
Die Schmerzintensität liegt 6 von 10.
Deswegen habe ich das Gespräch unterbricht und eine Ruhe EKG veranlasst.
Die Schmerzen werden entgenommen.
Die Patienten klagen über dauerhaftige Herzklopfen und Herzlasen.
Seit gestern haben sie eine dauernde Übelkeit ohne Erbrüche.
Die Patienten klagen über Schwitzen und Nachschweiß.
Die Patienten haben in den letzten 3 Jahren ca. 2 kg Zuhören.
Wegen Todangst und Schlafstörungen.
Die Vegetative Anamnesie ist unaufwendig.
Seit 5 Jahren haben die Patienten seit 10 Jahren dauerhaftige Hüsten mit gelbischem Auswurf.
Wegen Rauchen und Nikotinkonsum.
Mit 25. Lebensjahr erwähnte er wegen einer Cytamegalovirus-Infektion verroserte Lymphknoten.
Er hatte keine aktuellen Beschwerden.
Er gab sich vor 20. Lebensjahr wegen einem Unfall unter der Schenkeloperation durchgeführt.
Allergienanamnese ist unaufwendig und keine Unverträglichkeit bekannt.
Medikamenteur nimmt er täglich unklare Dosis Acetylsystem.
Ihrem Hausarzt rate ihn.
Bei der Nuchzenanamnese raucht er seit 18. Lebensjahr täglich 20 Zigaretten pro Tag.
In der letzten Zeit war der Nukotinkonsum etwas höher als früher.
Im Wochenende wurde der Alkoholkonsum von 1 oder 2 Gläsen Wein oder Bier verwendet.
Der Drogenkonsum wurde nur einmal verwendet.
Bei der Familienanamnese ergab er mit 55. Lebensjahr im Myokartenpfarzt bei meinem Vater daran verstorben.
So wie arterial Hypatonie und Gürneşta bei ihm bekannt.
Die Mutter leidet an rheumatischer Arthritis, das behandelt als Medikamentös.
Er hatte eine Schwester, die leidet über Gewicht sowie eine Depression und Walitzenkrankheiten.
Er ist ein Speditionkaufmann.
Er ist getrennt, hat eine Tochter, die Tochter ist gesund.
Anamnese haben mir das angesehen.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Ich habe eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Akutkronare-Syndrom.
Was bedeutet Akutkronare-Syndrom?
Akutkronare-Syndrom ist eine Verstopfung im Herzgefäß wegen Blutgefäße des Herzens.
Wir nennen das LED und DCA.
Wenn du nicht ganz genau erinnerst, kannst du es nicht nennen.
Du musst dich der Namen der Gefäße nennen.
Herzgefäße ist genug.
Eine Verstopfung im Herzgefäß.
Verengung oder Verstopfung im Herzgefäß.
Oder Verstopfung im Blutgefäß.
Herzgefäß ist besser.
Das ist spezifischer.
Und akutkronare-Syndrom umfasst welche Art von akutkronare-Syndrom.
Akutkronare-Syndrom ist eine Klassifikation oder ein System, der nicht mit einem Myokardinfarkt ist.
Das ist ein instabiler Angina.
Herzensym ist auffällig.
Und EKG-Veränderung.
Z.B. Erste Senkung oder Ersteigung.
Können Sie mir bitte helfen, was meinen Sie?
Sie haben sehr gute Antwort.
Stämme, nicht Stämme und Instabilen.
Kann ich in der Abrufung Stämme sagen?
Ja, Stämme.
Oder in Stämme können wir sagen?
Ist das die richtige Aussprache?
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich sage immer Stämme.
Ja, Stämme und Instabilen.
Am Anfang glaube ich, dass Stämme oder Instämme vielleicht falsch wird.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht falsch.
Instämme kann man auch sagen.
Was erwarten Sie bei Stämme?
Bei Stämme ist es auffällig.
EKG-Veränderung, es gibt eine Stärkung bei der St-Linie.
Die Stärkung ist sehr gut.
Es gibt auch eine Stärkung bei der Klinik.
Generell sind Brust-Klinik, engen Gefühle, Schmerzcharakter.
Die meisten sind am meisten drückend.
Und es ist sehr wichtig bei den Patienten Todangst.
Die Stärkung ist sehr wichtig.
Die Strahlung im Hals, Kiefer und linker Arm.
Das ist eine sehr wichtige Notfall-Situation.
Welchen Risikofaktor hat dieser Patient für Akut Koronare-Sendung?
Er hat eine Schachtel, Zigaretten und auch Alkohol.
Seit zwei Stunden hat er plötzlich aufgetretene Dumpf- und drückende Brustschmerzen.
Sie sind physisch. Wie groß ist er? Wie wiegt er?
Der Leitbadmessindex ist nicht auffällig.
Er ist 1,87 Meter groß und ca. 95 Kilo.
Wie groß ist er?
Der Leitbadmessindex ist nicht so hoch und nicht so klar auffällig.
Aber ich glaube, das ist der Grenz.
Ca. 25 Kilo. Aber nicht so wie ihre Schwester.
Das ist aber auch ein Risikofaktor.
Er kann ein Übergewicht sein. Er hat Grenzbadmessindex. Das ist auch ein Risikofaktor.
Wenn die Frau, die Sie über den Risikofaktor fragen,
dann sollen Sie zuerst Gewicht, dann Feuerkrankungen,
dann Genusmittel, Nikotinkonsum, Alkoholkonsum, Drogenkonsum,
dann Familienanamnese, dann Sozialanamnese, Beruf und Stress.
Dann antworten Sie.
Das ist der Badmessindex in Grenzen.
Ca. 25. Der Patient hat ca. 10 Jahre chronische Hüsten.
Der Patient raucht ca. über 20 Jahre.
Die Frau hat täglich eine Schachtelzigarette und Alkohol konsumiert.
Bei der Familienanamnese gab es an,
der Vater ist wegen einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Er leidet unter Arbeitsbelastung.
Ihre Schwester ist übergewicht.
Sie sollen alle Teile gucken, dann sagen Sie nur wichtige Informationen.
Chronische Hüsten sind nicht wichtig.
Aber wenn er an arteriälichem Pertonil leidet, dann können Sie es.
Sie haben recht, das ist eine Befunde, nicht Risikofaktoren.
Ich möchte noch fragen, ob bei der Schwester übergewicht
ein Risikofaktor ist. Darf ich sagen oder soll ich sagen?
Sie können sagen, weil er auf Grenzen Badmessindex hat.
Normalerweise kann er auf Erblich sein.
Am wichtigsten ist, dass sein Vater an Herzinfarkt gestorben ist.
Welcher Fernsehdiagnostik kommt in Betracht?
Die Fernsehdiagnostik kommt in Betracht
Gastroesophäische Reflexkrankheit und Lungenembolie.
Hinter dem Brustbein und chronischen Hüsten.
Warum denken Sie an Gastroesophäische Reflexkrankheit oder Lungenembolie?
Er hat ca. 10 Jahre chronische Hüsten und keine bekannten Diagnosen.
Er hat lange nicht in ihrem Hausarzt besucht.
Er hat noch eine Schlafstörung und fühlt sich übel.
Schmerzen hinter dem Brustbein könnte sein.
Sie erwarten auf diese Beschwerden bei Gastroesophäischer Reflex auch?
Ja, weil es sehr viel Nikotinkonsum und Alkoholkonsum gibt.
Deswegen könnte es sein.
Welche weitere Diagnostik muss das sein?
Ich habe noch Lungenembolie gedacht.
Weil plötzlich aufgetretene Schmerzen hinter dem Brustbein.
Atemnot und ein enges Gefühl.
Deswegen habe ich die Fernsehdiagnostik Lungenembolie gedacht.
Okay.
Weitere Diagnostik?
Ich habe schon körperliche Untersuchungen,
bin in Laboanbetracht und durchgeführt.
Weiter in eine Ruh- und Kontroll-EKG durchführen.
Und Herz-Engime wieder kontrollieren.
Tropon-E, Kratinkinase-E, MB.
Und Nieren- und Lebewerte.
Und noch eine Elektro- und Eko-Kardiographie durchführen.
Damit die Lungenembolie nicht schliessen können.
Die Gelunkeparameter, Fibonade, D-Demal und Allergen, PTT und INR.
Das kann man kontrollieren.
Wenn der Dema negativ ist,
können Sie Lungenembolie ausschließen?
An uns nicht, kann ich nicht genau sagen.
Ich weiß, aber ich bin mir nicht sicher.
Wenn der Dema negativ ist,
können wir Lungenembolie oder TFT ausschließen.
Aber wenn der Dema positiv ist,
sagen wir nicht sofort TFT oder Lungenembolie.
Dass der Patient Lungenembolie oder TFT hat.
Bei D-Demal kann aufgrund vieler verschiedenen Ursachen aufsteigen.
Bei uns, zum Beispiel in der Türkei, 2014,
bei einem weiblichen Patienten,
ohne D-Demal-Steigerung,
kommt eine Lungenembolie.
Daran ist sie verstorben.
Wie gesagt, habe ich mich mir nicht sicher.
Ja, das ist ein
als theoretisches Zeug, aber ein praktisches Zeug.
Aber ich bin mir sicher, dass das der Herr Abraham ist.
Ich bin hier ein bisschen von den Noten ausgeschaut,
aber die Stämme ist unstabil.
Hier ist keine stabile Angina.
Wir müssen das kurz hören.
Also, dass es eine Chance gibt.
Dann können wir es enden.
Aber stabile Angina kommt nicht in den Akutkörner-Syndrom.
Das ist die chronische Herzkrankheit.
Stabil Angina ist Stemi und Nistemi.
Das ist Akutkörner-Syndrom.
Aber das kann nicht in die Stimte kommen.
Es gibt auch Nostemia, Nonhormoneemia.
Ich denke, dass es in die Stimte kommen wird.
Aber Stemi, Nistemi oder Stabil Angina-Pictures sind die Besten.
Okay.
Wie können Sie die Patienten behandeln?
Unser Protokoll ist momentan.
Erstmal ist eine Sedation sehr wichtig für uns.
Morphine, ca. 3 mg, HIV, Infusion.
Und gegebenenfalls eine Sauerstoff-Substitution mit Maske unter 90% ist sehr wichtig.
Und gegebenenfalls, wenn es nicht kontraindiziert, Nitroglycerin.
Wie ein Kassium-Kanal-Hemma.
Isosorbidmonohydrat oder Isosorbid-Dichydrat.
Bei dem rechtseitigen Herzinfarkt oder bei der Hypertonie kontraindiziert.
Und AAS 300 mg ist eine Routine.
Prophylaxe und Heparin.
5.000 international enzyme units.
Wenn es eine Stand durchgeführt wurde,
dann könnten wir 600 mg oral verabreichen.
Was sollen Sie machen, wenn Sie eine EKG-Veränderung bestimmen?
Was sollen Sie sofort machen?
EKG-Veränderung zum Beispiel, wenn Sie eine STH-Taggung oder...
Ja, eine STH-Bung.
Erstmal, ich denke, Antikoabulation ist sehr wichtig.
Und Oxygen-Sattürung.
Aus dieser Maßnahmen.
Ja, aus dieser Maßnahmen.
Meinten und Unterzocken Methoden ist sehr wichtig.
Und eine Kardiologe ist konzertlich anfordend.
Sofort.
An wichtigsten ist Kardiologe ist konzertlich.
Wenn Sie diese Maßnahmen durchführen, gleichzeitig rufen Sie...
Ja, Kardiologe.
Und eine coronare Angiografie.
Oder sofort eine STH-Angiografie.
Ja, je nach Befundement der Unterzockung,
kann eine coronare Angiografie gegebenenfalls
per kurzen coronare Intervention...
Ja.
Ja, zuführend werden.
Ja, wir denken, wir notifizieren...
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Vielen Dank.
Kardiologe ist konzertlich.
Ich warte, ich habe gewartet, dass du Kardiologe ist konzertlich nennst.
Aber Sie haben nicht gesagt.
Deswegen habe ich wieder gesagt.
Normalerweise.
Momentan bin ich bereit.
Sorry, ich sage so oft.
Als Kardiologe.
Kardiologe rufen, aber...
Aber bevor möchte ich eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, natürlich, aber ich bin nicht bereit.
Ekrem, ich finde, dass du es sehr gut gemacht hast.
Du hast es vorhin gesehen.
Du fühlst dich sicherer und sicherer.
Du hast die Patientin sehr gut gemacht,
wenn sie die Anamnesie macht.
Es war keine Läden.
Manchmal ist es so, dass die Patientin etwas sagt,
aber wenn du die Anamnesie gut benutzt,
und die Anamnesie in einer entsprechenden Art aufwenden,
wird die Wahrheit mehr.
Das wird dir auch die Zeit gewinnen.
Denn die Patientin sagt, dass sie es schon gesagt hat.
Dann kümmern Sie sich auf die Zeit.
Aber außerdem, dass Sie die Fragen stellen,
alles beobachten,
das alles ist sehr gut.
Ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg.
Und wie gesagt, die Gefühl, die Sie auf die andere Seite geben,
die man auf die Pfrüfer oder die Rückstellung…
… ja, es gibt die Gefühl, dass sie sicherer,
die Patientin eine volle Ordnung haben,
und die Patientin alles machen kann.
Deswegen ist dies ein sehr wesentlicher Abschluss,
diese Gefühle zu haben.
Die Grundlage dafür ist, dass man sich selbst
sicherer fühlt, das zu beуже,
aber das ist gut.
Auch auf die Ausweise,
also auch im Vorstellungssinn,
Natürlich, verbliebene Verben werden manchmal vergessen, besonders Zintler.
In Zint- oder Zint- oder Zint-Sagen, die ihr verwenden müsst, verblieben Sie sie.
Herr, ich habe zwei Monate vorher einen Zint- oder Zint-Sagen.
Aber beachten Sie sich auf das.
Dann sind Ihre Sagen sehr schön, aber wenn sie nicht sind,
woher sucht man eine Feele? Woher sagt man jetzt diese Feele?
Wenn ich Zainer oder so eine Feele anbiete, werde ich mich entspannt machen,
aber ich bin in Zint gezwungen.
Du wirst in Zainer oder in Zint anbieten.
Ich muss zurückkommen, Herr.
Besonders ist es sehr gut, also,
ich wünsche Ihnen viel Erfolg,
und ich hoffe, dass Sie die restliche Zeit mit viel Praxis machen.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie die Übung in ein schönes Modus geben,
mit der Gnade des Allgäu.
Okay.
So.
Herr Ibrahim, bitte.
Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Akpinal.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten gesehen,
aber bevor ich diesen Patienten vorstelle,
möchte ich Ihnen eine kurze Anmerkung machen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, aber das vergessen Sie.
Bei Ekrame.
Ja, aber gleich habe ich einen Anruf aus dem Labor bekommen.
Unbedingt soll ich Ihnen berichten,
dass Frau Schäffer einen Natriumwert von 168 Millimitern pro Liter hat.
Dieser Wert ist deutlich erhöht
und entspricht Hypernatremia.
Nun würde ich gerne den ersten Patienten präsentieren.
Ja, natürlich, bitte schön.
Es geht um Herrn Florian Wilms.
Er ist ein 42-jähriger Patient, geboren am 2.02.1982.
Herr Wilms kam heute zu uns wegen seit zwei Stunden
plötzlich aufgetretener Rhetostimulbrustmessen in Ruhe,
mit Austrahlung in den linken Arm.
Der Patient beschreibt die Schmerzen als Druck und Dumpfes Siehen.
Die Schmerzintensität lag bei 4 von 10 auf der NRS.
Früher lag es bei 6 von 10 auf der NRS.
Die Schmerzintensität lag bei 8 von 10, früher momentan lag es bei 6 von 10 auf der NRS.
Ich erinnere mich nicht an die Dinge, aber du hast jetzt gesagt lag, dann momentan.
Lag beinhaltet das Geheimnis, momentan beinhaltet es.
Da gibt es einen Grammatik-Hat, sag Füria, dann momentan liegt es bei 6 von 10 auf der NRS.
Momentan lag es bei 4 von 10 auf der NRS.
Herr Wilms berichtete, dass Schmerzen im Verlauf der Zeit schlimmer geworden sind.
Aber momentan werden Schmerzintensität niedrig.
Ich glaube nicht nur die Schmerzen berichtet er.
Er hat seit einem Jahr ähnliche Beschwerden.
Früher waren die Beschwerden leichter.
Zum Beispiel die Beschwerden haben sehr kurze gedauert und nur bei Belastung aufgetreten und danach selbst verschwunden.
Aber momentan sind sie in der Ruhe aufgetreten, so lange gedauert und nicht selbst verschwunden.
Das bedeutet, dass die Zeit schlimmer geworden ist.
Anderer Formulierung kann ich sagen.
Darüber hinaus gab er an, dass die Ähnliche Beschwerden seit einem Jahr bestehen.
Früher hatte er zwei, drei Malige Schmerzen.
Ist das richtig?
Ja, bei dieser Erklärung können Sie sagen, mit der Zeit sind die Beschwerden schlimmer geworden.
Diese Satze ist eine solche Erklärung.
Begleitend klagt er über Herzrasen, Müdigkeit, Schwitzen, Rübelkeit, Kaltschweiß, Vegetative-Anemnistisch, Ergapsicht, Vegetative-Anemnistisch ist unauffällig bis auf Insomnia.
Als Vorerkrankungen leidet er an chronische Hürsten seit zehn Jahren und Medikamentos nimmt er mit unklarer Dosierung morgen einmal pro Tag.
In der operativen Anamnese findet sich eine Osteosynthose mit 20 Lebensjahren ohne Komplikationen.
Bistruecklich der Allergie und Unvertrechlichkeiten ist unauffällig.
Herr Wilms ist Raucher seit 18 Jahren und ungefähr 20 Zigaretten täglich konsumiert.
Herr Wilms trinkt ein bis zwei Flaschen Bier und drei bis drei Gläser am Wochenende.
Er ist Spedition Kaufmann, hat eine gesunde Tochter und getrennt.
Die Familienanamnese ergab eine arterielle Hypertonie, eine Herzkrankheitserkrankung und ein Glockon bei der Mutter,
eine Adipositas, eine Depression und eine Wärme insuffizient bei der Schwester.
Reiseanamnese und Impfungsstatus sind beide unauffällig.
Auf der anamnestischen Angabe habe ich einen Verdacht auf akutes Coronasyndrom.
Die typischen Symptomatik ist eine akute Brustschmerzen mit Ausstellung in den linken Arm.
Die Risikofaktoren sind eine lange Zeit Rauchen und Familienveranlagung.
Ihr Vater hat einen Herzinfarkt und ist mit 50 Lebensjahren verstorben.
Ich habe früher eine Differenzialdiagnostik.
Ich habe eine Lungenarterielleembolie und eine gastroesophagische Reflexkrankheit.
Wenn ich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätige, würde ich weitere Tests durchführen.
Früher habe ich eine EKG geschrieben und das Blut vor der Labose abgenommen.
Ich habe eine Eko-Kardiographie veranlasst.
Diese Methode dient zur Abklärung der Herz- und Klappenfunktion.
Wenn ich meine Verdachtdiagnose bestätige, würde ich die Intensivstation der Patienten aufnehmen.
Wenn ich Antipilatien und Anticoagulantherapie zurückverbrechen würde, würde ich eine kardiologische Konsil anordnen.
Wie ist die Technik?
Ich schaue die Fragen an.
Ich kann die Technik aus der Herst- und der Herz-Kranz-Gefäß-Ausgabe nennen.
Ich kann die Technik aus der Herst- und Herz-Kranz-Gefäß-Ausgabe nennen.
Die Eko-Kranz-Gefäß-Ausgabe ist eine der wichtigsten Methoden für die Diagnose des Vita.
Die Stabilisierung ist nur mit Effort.
Sie ist in der Entstehung und nicht in der Entstehung.
Ich weiß das.
Kann ich ein paar Äckungen für den Test machen?
Ich würde es gut machen, wenn jemand, der nicht kardiologisch ist, die Arztin oder die Doktorin, die Kornorangeografie nicht so oft sagt.
Ich habe hier keine Kornorangeographie gesprochen.
Ich habe mich wie ein Kardiolog nicht gefühlt.
Die Patienten, die in den Urlaub kommen, müssen die EKG-Test machen.
Sofort haben wir die E-Testung beendet.
Wenn wir in der E-Testung kommen, dann ist es gut, dass wir die E-Testung beenden.
Ich habe es vorhin in einigen Simulationen gehört.
Ich möchte die Testungen auf die Kornorangeographie.
Wenn es notwendig ist, kann ich die E-Testung neu beenden, wenn es schwer ist.
Ich möchte eine Kardiologik-Konstellation aufgrund der Kornorangeographie.
Aber das ist so, dass der Kornorangeographie nicht so oft sagt, dass er das machen wird.
Aber ein kardiologischer Arzt muss auch immer wissen, was ein Kornorangeographie machen wird.
In allen Fällen sind die Kornorangeographie nicht so oft zu sagen, dass er das machen wird.
Aber in dem Falle ist das so.
Ich mache auch keine ERCP-Testungen.
Aber in dem Falle in Köln, das ich nicht verstanden habe,
ist das Erforderlichste, dass er das Kornorangeographie nicht so oft beenden wird.
Ich möchte hier eine Kardiologik-Konstellation aufnehmen.
Und dann sage ich, dass er das Kornorangeographie nicht so oft beenden wird.
Ich weiß, dass es so ein Krankheit ist, aber ich weiß nicht, wie es gemacht wird.
Ich weiß nicht, was passiert, aber ich weiß, dass es so etwas ist.
Ich kann es so aussehen. Aber wann soll ich das sagen?
Wenn ich das beantragen will.
Das kann also nach den Ergebnissen notwendig sein.
Was bedeutet das? Das kann ich mir beitragen.
Das war sehr schön.
Die Erfurt-Ellixation war wirklich sehr schön.
Ich habe eine Frage zu Akutkornersendormen gestellt.
Akutkornersendormen sind drei.
Inch Tablangina Pectoris, ST-Elevation, ST-Heibung und Non-ST-Heibung.
Die Klinik der Patientin ist so.
Sie sagt, sie hat sechs.
Dann sind es vier.
Das ist ein bisschen komisch.
Akutkornersendormen kommen mit einer gewissen Gewalt.
Das ist ein bisschen instabil.
Sie sagt seine Rechte.
Und sie sagt, sie ist nicht ST-Elevation.
Diese Geschichte passt nicht mit ST-Elevation.
Die Geschichte, die wir in der Simulation haben,
passt nicht mit ST-Elevation oder nicht mit ST-Elevation.
ST-Elevation und MI sind sehr schwer.
Wenn so eine Frage kommt, sind es mindestens acht.
Das heißt, die ST-Elevation-MI sind schwer.
Auch Frauen halten sich bei der Geburt an.
Die Stachhaut, die Stichhaut.
Wir können nicht mit den Stichhauten kümmern.
Das ist das Stichhaut von Frauen.
Und der Stichhaut aus der Stichhaut.
Die Patienten sind nicht einfach.
Deshalb ist die Stichhaut ein stiles Problem.
Aber der Stichhaut ist ein stiles Problem.
Aber das Stichhaut ist ein stiles Problem.
Ich kann es nicht sagen, wenn es eine Frage gibt.
Ich denke nicht auf die S-Levelation.
Die Intensität ist 4.
Das ist nicht die S-Levelation.
Aber es kann auch Instabilangine sein.
Oder es kann auch Noneste sein.
Das wollte ich so beweisen.
Aber ich bin sehr verabschiedet, Prof. İbrahim.
Ich kann es nicht sagen.
Wir können nicht feststellen, welches Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom das ist.
Deswegen nennen wir es Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom.
Wenn man sich die Frage stellt,
kann ich das nicht sagen.
Ich kann es nicht sagen,
aber ich muss die S-Levelation und die Blutwerte sehen.
Das wäre besser.
Vielleicht kann man das sagen.
Wenn der Blutwerte normal ist,
kann man die Pulmonenembolie in den Akut-Coronavirus-Syndrom verabschieden.
Wenn der Blutwerte über 500 ist,
muss man einen Prozess auf den Blutwerte.
Wenn der Blutwerte über 1000 ist,
Was ist mit Blutwerte statt Fibrinojen?
Fibrinojen ist ein Zerstöckel.
Das ist nicht ein Test, den wir in Pulmonenembolien kennen.
Nur wenn man sich auf die Koagulationen befindet,
wird Fibrinojen ausgelöst.
Also ein Ticket?
Ja.
Fibrinojen ist kaputt und wird in den Fibrin geübt.
Die D-Dimer wüften.
Die D-Dimer wüften und die Fibrin wird kaputt gemacht.
Was anderes ist die Tätigkeit.
Wenn ihr Zeit habt, würde ich etwas reden.
Hier ist Aspirin 300 mg Intravenous.
Hier ist Klopidogrel.
Es gibt noch ein paar, aber das kann nicht sein.
Wir wissen es, aber Klopidogre rettet sich im Test.
600 mg.
Teparin-E-Fau.
Hier sind die Noten auf 5000 Unite.
Das ist 70 Kilogramm.
60 Kilo für eine Frau ist 5000 Unite.
100 Kilo für eine Frau ist 5000 Unite.
Das ist 70 Kilogramm.
100 Kilo für eine Frau ist 7000 Unite.
60 Kilo für eine Frau ist 4000 Unite.
Das sind 4200 Unite.
70 Kilogramm.
Das ist nicht direkt 1000 Unite.
Das ist nur Kilogramm.
Außerdem gibt es Morphin als Aarikessiker.
Aber es gibt auch viele Abwechslungen.
Wir geben auch Petidin.
Aber wir lieben es nicht.
Es ist sehr schwierig.
Du arbeitest immer mit Kussmuss.
Es ist MI-abwechslung.
Und Morphin muss man vorsichtig machen.
Vor allem Antiemetik.
Um nicht zu verabschieden.
Zitron, Zoffer.
Das kann man in der ganzen Welt oder in der Medipamidipotensiv-Diese vergeben.
Und wir geben 3 Medikamente.
Aspirin, Klopidogrel und Heparin.
Das sind die grundlegenden Medikamente.
Wenn man nur klopidogrel gibt, dann gibt es prasugrel.
Das ist eine Technik.
Das ist ein Ticac-Roller.
Das ist nicht für uns.
Aber es steht in den Noten.
Es steht in den Noten.
Es steht, dass es eine Kardiologen-Einrichtung gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viel ich im Test muss.
Ich versuche nur, einen rückwärtsigen Begriff zu machen.
Wenn man die E-Level-Einrichtung sieht, muss man direkt in die Anjou-Einrichtung gehen.
Sie sagen 90 Minuten, aber das ist die kürze Zeit.
Das ist die kürze Zeit.
Es gibt 24-70 Stunden im Instabilang, die keine E-Level-Einrichtung haben.
Aber das ist die kürze Zeit.
Also, die kürze Zeit, die möglich ist, ist die Anjou-Einrichtung.
Ist es noch eine Frage?
Ist die Anjou-Einrichtung noch eine Frage?
Geht alle E-Level-Einrichtungen in die Anjou-Einrichtung?
Das ist eine Frage.
Denkt man sich an die Gönnensache, an die Troponopositiv-Einrichtung,
dann ist die Anjou-Einrichtung überhaupt.
Aber ist die Troponopositiv-Einrichtung die Anjou-Einrichtung?
Nein, das ist eine Unverschämtheit.
Also, alle E-Level-Einrichtungen gehen in die Anjou-Einrichtung,
aber ist die Troponopositiv-Einrichtung nicht die Anjou-Einrichtung?
Es sind alle unsere Kräfte.
Wenn ein Patient mit einer Troponin-Ausgabe, die Troponin-Ausgabe ist, sehr generell ist das ein Problem.
Er kann in den Testen kommen.
Troponin-Ausgabe, aber die Kreativität der Patientin ist 2,5.
Ob er sofort in die Anjou ist, ist nicht zu beantworten.
Was ist Troponin-Ausgabe?
Troponin-A und T sind aus der Troponin-Ausgabe enthalten.
Da es in der Troponin-Ausgabe enthalten ist, kann es ein liarliches Positiv sein.
Ob es ein Patient mit einer Herzstelle ist, kann es ein liarliches Positiv sein.
Das ist eine sehr wichtige Information.
Das ist eine sehr praktisch verhandelte Situation.
Vielen Dank.